today is a very special video first I
get to embarrass myself by giving you a
look into how I record audio and how
often I it up when doing it can't
do it we'll do it live well do it why
and second I get to announce that
pre-orders of the audiobook version of
the Able's are now available through
audible.com narrated by yours truly
not only are the audiobook and ebook
versions available but this is your last
chance to preorder physical copies as
well because the book is shipping we
didn't know it would they're supposed to
be made first but it's going out you
still have time to order and get
exclusive sins videos if you go to the
Able's book comm and send us your order
number for the audiobook ebook or
physical copy fill out that little form
you stopped on but once May first hits
the old official release date the
preorder sach will end and that chance
is gone more importantly if you sign up
for audible today you'll get your first
audiobook free and in unrelated news
again I narrated the entire audiobook
for the Able's you guys have made a
dream of mine reality not the audio book
it's the book of general actually the
recording of the audio book was pretty
grueling as you'll see here in a minute
but I can't thank you enough for being
awesome people I've flown too high on
borrowed wings I really hope that you
enjoy the book and if you like the book
please review it on amazon and when you
get your copy post a picture of it
anywhere online with the hashtag the
Able's and i'll do my best to find it
and thank you person now without further
ado here are some of the best and by
best I mean most embarrassing outtakes
from the recording process of the
audiobook for the Able's lectures
opening with our full first name and
this variety almost always has the
lingering but the also the length of
pause I would rather have I would rather
have that yeah why do I write I wrote
this alright what the hell am i doing
I'm going back to the beginning of this
paragraph as we reach the door that led
from the kitchen to the garage my mother
and little brother came into the mom had
mastered the art of yelling at one child
while talking to another she had also
mastered the art of seeing things
peripherally
wow that's gonna take eight tries ah
alright here we go
she had also mastered the art of seeing
things peripherally peripherally got
just so you know there's always once in
person's video or I have to do it like
20 times and I'm really mad
by the end so I could still hear her
shouting at a moose some days our
proximity and age made Pat and I
inseparable I shouldn't have done this I
can get through the big word but then I
forgot the little one the old man you
keep inviting over the buck some days
our proximity and age made Pat and I
inseparable best friends I think I said
breast friends I tried to act casual but
wasn't remotely convincing me I know I'm
just resetting myself before I start
self-loathing I heard some chickens
chucking Chucky my father my whole
family for that matter even Patrick was
very good about setting the scene for me
when we went to someplace new to help me
visualize the Charette damn it stomach
join the track when you pay as much
attention to sound but I seriously doubt
that you know what we're here and your
mother and I think it's time for you to
know a lot more about much of what he
was saying was slipping right past me
while I mostly just heard the word
superhero a current occurring as it
always as it has a as it is as it has me
there's another typo I've typos all over
this damn book bird just flew by on the
window outside and the shadow convinced
me a bunny had just run by on the floor
to pardon a break I think we better get
headed oh I don't like it at all
all right he reached into the center
console compartment and pulled out a
fish a fish I wondered if my blindness
might limit my own ability more than my
able-bodied hero but I brushed aside but
I brushed it aside do you that's some
good Angry outtakes they're pulling a
pump but I thought the characters in the
Able's are outcasts they're disabled
kids they're viewed as less worthy in
their society in their culture and I
think everybody feels like that at some
point in the real world
everybody goes through periods of their
life where they feel outcast and
downtrodden I think it's pretty evident
when you read the book that it's one of
my beliefs that shouldn't let those
kinds of things no disability no
difference no strangeness keep you from
being who you are knowing you have
ability to do great things
creating the things you want to create
whether that means you're a superhero
with disabilities you go be a superhero
if it means you're not a superhero with
disabilities but you've always wanted to
write a book write that damn book
I encourage you
you